a new shipment from China and earhart
vishal is checking to make sure
everything is as it should be michelle
has been importing bicycle parts from
China for decades until recently the
only way he could pay for them was in
u.s. dollars that created problems when
the exchange rate worked against him
linseed honest it used to be that when
you paid for something in China they
would calculate a slowly declining
dollar yes like the doll off up so when
you bought something say a lot of order
that was only going to be delivered in
six months wasn't often you would end up
paying two percent more than the dollar
price when you ordered by Putin who go
there were years when that cost him as
much as 300 thousand euros and the
clearing process was slow and
complicated so when bisha learned that
the bank of china was opening renminbi
accounts in frankfurt a few months ago
he worked with his local bag to organize
payments in the chinese currency
he is a pioneer as you cal 15 National
Novel this is really only the beginning
I think in the middle we have many
different mid-sized companies as
customers and when I'm visiting them I
tell them they can now pay in renminbi I
ask them to speak to their business
partners about it yeah these are really
early days we make suggestions yeah but
the reality is that not so much is
happening at the moment our tad late
leash pacient would lie down roaring ah
nice off-year that Bish's strongly
recommends that anyone who does a lot of
business in china open air in min be
account and make payments with it he's
regularly in China and has been
following the liberalisation of the
country's currency he's a no doubt that
he made the right choice it swooped
fakir it immune be in the future the
renminbi will be a normal currency final
does no real difference to the dollar
and some no different than the power it
will be a strong currencies of it
because a lot of deals are done in
renminbi and China's currency reserves
are relatively large franchina uh what
was it Vishal already pays for most of
his imports from China with the renminbi
and he says the proportion of renminbi
payments will continue to increase